the Iraqi government has condemned US
air strikes on Military positions in the
country the Prime Minister says
Washington's actions undermine years of
collaboration between the two Nations
the attacks on three sites in Western
Iraq were associated with katab
Hezbollah and Iran supported armed group
two people were killed the US says the
strikes were a retaliation for missile
attacks on American troops and Coalition
Personnel in Iraq and Syria well for
more on this let bring in Ali amori a
political analyst and civil societ
coordinator he joins us from Baghdad
thank you very much for joining us here
on El jazer first of all can we start
with the US strikes in Iraq can you just
give us a little bit of context about
these militias and their involvement in
the region who are they and and why are
they backed by
Iran uh well these militias has been U
working in Iraq for a long time they are
part of the popular mobilization and
they have participated in defeating
dases during their invasion in the
northern part of Iraq and they are
backed by Iran like many other militias
uh for a long time the the United States
has said that these strikes are in
response to an attack on its basis in
Iraq and in Syria is this an abuse of
the security agreement between the US
and Iraq like Iraq's government
claims well the conflict and
the continuous uh uh air strikes done by
the United States and by these militias
on military bases where United State
Army is based has been ongoing before
Gaza and now it's more happening after
what's happening in Gaza and Palestine
so uh these strikes is quite unfortunate
because it doesn't solve the problem and
it might lead to more escalation of the
situation Iraqi people in general feel
that uh some of them we shouldn't be
involved in this conflict in general and
some others feels it's a responsibility
of these military groups to support uh
the people in Palestine and Gaza does it
feel there that uh Iraq is being sucked
into this conflict against its
will uh probably some may Fe that but at
the same time Iraq is heavily involved
in the in the region and uh Iraq has a
good relationship with Iran and Iran of
course is taking the side of the
Palestinians against the aggressors and
the occupi the Israelis and we feel as
long as there are multi Powers including
of course the United States who are
supporting Israel that in turn we have
as well to support the Palestinians with
whatever we can yeah in relation to uh
the US's relationship with Iraq I mean
Iraq's government has said that this
undermines years of cooperation between
the two countries is that all at risk
now absolutely and uh just a few weeks
ago the Prime Minister has called for
the American troops to to leave the
country and uh that we are no longer in
Need for the support of the American uh
troops or the American consultants in
military consultants and unfor this is
quite unfortunate because
eventually uh it's important to have U
normal uh relationship with the United
States but at the same time United
States should realize the situation in
the Middle East and in order to have
peace and prosperity for the people of
the Middle East we have to solve the
root causes which is happening all
around us whether in Palestine whether
in in Syria whether in Yemen and as long
as this is ongoing of course the normal
relationship with the United States will
be much affected we'll have to leave it
there but thank you so much for your
time and your Insight that is Ali amori
there for Us in
Baghdad